So you might be asking, who's going to pay?
Well, I'm going to argue that governments
should fund sanitation infrastructure.
NGOs and donor organizations,
they can do their best, but it's not going to be enough.
Governments should fund sanitation
the same way they fund roads
and schools and hospitals
and other infrastructure like bridges,
because we know, and the WHO has done this study,
that for every dollar that we invest
in sanitation infrastructure,
we get something like three to 34 dollars back.
Let's go back to the problem of pit emptying.
So at North Carolina State University,
we challenged our students to come up with a simple solution,
and this is what they came up with:
a simple, modified screw auger
that can move the waste up
from the pit and into a collecting drum,
and now the pit worker
doesn't have to go down into the pit.
We tested it in South Africa, and it works.
We need to make it more robust,
and we're going to do more testing
in Malawi and South Africa this coming year.
And our idea is to make this
a professionalized pit-emptying service
so that we can create a small business out of it,
create profits and jobs,
and the hope is that,
as we are rethinking sanitation,
we are extending the life of these pits
so that we don't have to resort
to quick solutions
that don't really make sense.
I believe that access to adequate sanitation
is a basic human right.
We need to stop the practice
of lower castes and lower-status people
going down and being condemned to empty pits.
It is our moral, it is our social
and our environmental obligation.
Thank you.
(Applause)